good morning Hank it's Monday I woke up
early on Queen's Day here in Amsterdam
because Henry was all like I don't
always wake up at 5:40 2:00 in the
morning but when I do I expect to be fed
the Yeti and I dressed him in a dirt
couch Jersey and headed down to the
Vondelpark about mourning the streets of
Amsterdam were abandoned and only ducks
were on the canals although the
porta-potties in the distance hinted
that a party was brewing as we walked
with has this Emily Dickinson poem to
make a prairie it takes a clover and 1b1
clover and a bee and reverie the reverie
alone will do if bees are few when we
got to the Vondelpark families we're
already setting up their stations for
the free market which is so called
because none of the items in it are free
not even the back issues of Donald Duck
Comics Queen's Day is a celebration of
Queen Beatrix is Mother's birthday and
it involves this strange citywide garage
sale where people sell artwork and old
clothes and unicycle with hula hoops for
tips and offer carnival games and oh my
god to be a kid on a lake in a bubble it
was pretty great but Henry just wanted
to play in the sandbox he was like guys
look at this stuff it is amazing after a
while we walked back to the apartment I
watched thousands of people streaming
downtown and then I met up with
nerdfighter Toby oz who was the only
person in all of Amsterdam not wearing
orange I've looked at my board aw man I
didn't have anything orange you're
embarrassing yourself starting to be a
little anxious why
because the number of people who are
here and also wearing orange which is a
very anxious color for me there were no
more ducks in the canals and no more
empty streets just a lot of people and
free inflatable hats now that we got
these hats is definitely a party we
finally made it down to the museum plan
were a hundred thousand drunk people
were listening to music whereupon Tobias
tried to teach me how to say Queen's Day
in Dutch on minun and dog running in
enough corn in another cone regarding a
dog we got photobombed quite a lot down
there in the museum vine on the walk
home topi honest and I had an
impassioned discussion in read the
provenance of this liquid and then he
bought a biography of Elton John at a
free market we just saw a guy trading
underwear for rice krispie treats which
is the kind of thing that like does
happen but not at 2:20 in the afternoon
finally after an hour of pushing through
crowds I made it home techno was
rattling our apartment but I was happy
to live in a world that finds cause to
celebrate
and happier still that by law the party
ended at 9 p.m. that's just good
government regulation at work Hank I'll
see you on Wednesday
you